invité sur rtl france infirmier à
l'hôpital robert debré membres du
collectif inter urgence laurent
rubinstein a du mal à croire en ce ségur
de la santé qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il va y avoir des améliorations
mais je pense qu'ils vont pas qu'ils
vont pas être suffisante vers l'hôpital
s'est inscrit depuis un an et demi
là on a eu copie on va nous dire ah oui
c'est bon il ya ulcos vip qui est passé
donc on va les revaloriser mais
franchement j'ai du mal ay croire
on a fait tellement de plan entre agnès
buzyn qui a fait des plans ma santé 2022
et après qu'on dit que même le président
de la république on soit ali ben
finalement c'est caduque et il ya des
choses qui pour revoir et le nouveau
ministre de la santé qui arrive et qu'il
y avait je vais faire un nouveau plan le
plan c ur et que finalement je
franchement on est on est dans des
doutes on est dans on ne sait pas
comment ça va avancer on sait vraiment
pas où on est en fait on sait pas ce que
va vraiment devenir la santé et ce que
va vraiment devenir nos métiers